lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
presentar la idea de una integral
definida y junto con las integrales
indefinidas y las derivadas este es uno
de los pilares del cálculo en futuros
vídeos veremos que todos estos elementos
están relacionados y veremos de dónde
viene la anotación de la integral
definida vamos a dibujar algunas
funciones aquí y pensemos en áreas bajo
la curva vamos a dibujar un eje ordenado
aquí este es el eje y este es el eje x y
aquí dibujamos otro par de ejes
ordenados aquí tenemos una función f x y
aquí tenemos el valor x que es igual
aa ponemos una línea aquí y ese es el
valor de x que es igual a ver nos
interesa el área bajo la curva de la
función y igual a fx por arriba del eje
x que se encuentra entre estos dos
límites x es igual a y x es igual a b
pueden apreciar que no estamos
acostumbrados a calcular el área de
figuras donde uno de los lados o muchos
de los lados
veremos más adelante este curvado pero
esa es una de las cosas poderosas de la
integral definida y del cálculo integral
con respecto a la anotación para esta
área será la integral definida luego
tenemos el límite inferior x que es
igual aa aquí arriba ponemos el límite
superior que es x igual a b queremos el
área bajo la curva fx y luego ponemos de
x en el futuro y especialmente cuando
veamos las sumas de ruymán
comprenderemos mejor de dónde viene esta
anotación que de hecho viene del leibniz
uno de los fundadores del cálculo este
es el símbolo de suma pero para el
propósito de este vídeo nos interesa
conocer lo que representa todo esto
representa el área bajo la curva fx
entre x iguala y x igual a b este valor
y esta expresión deben ser iguales en la
forma en la que lo dibujé aquí se trata
de un área positiva y se lo que están
pensando
acaso no todas las áreas son positivas
pues sí deben ser positivas pero cuando
hacemos que las cosas
consistentes matemáticamente en las
integrales definidas resulta que podemos
tener áreas negativas debemos tener esto
en cuenta cómo podemos tener un área
negativa una situación es cuando tenemos
el área por debajo del eje x digamos que
nuestra función se comporta así aquí
tenemos el límite y aquí tenemos el
límite b cuando tenemos esta situación
donde la curva está por debajo del eje
en el rango que nos interesa calcular el
área que por cierto esta expresión
también puede representar esta área aquí
tendremos un área negativa en el futuro
cuando veamos las propiedades de las
integrales en especial las propiedades
de las integrales definidas veremos que
si hacen el número más grande el límite
inferior y el número más pequeño el
límite superior aún cuando la función se
encuentre por arriba del eje x tendremos
un área negativa además tendremos
situaciones combinadas por ejemplo ahora
a está aquí y b está acá
el área que nos interesa tendrá un
segmento positivo y un segmento negativo
por lo que se cancelará cierta parte de
esta área negativa que es más grande así
que cuando evaluemos esta integral
el resultado será negativo si por el
contrario el área positiva fuera más
grande que el área negativa el resultado
será positivo usemos lo que ya sabemos
sobre las integrales definidas para
resolver algunos ejemplos aquí tenemos
la gráfica de igual a fx traten de
calcular esto cuál es la integral
definida desde menos 12 a menos 2 de fx
de x pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo por su cuenta esto nos dice
que el área bajo la curva de fx por
arriba del eje x y que va de menos 12 a
menos 2 estoy señalando el área que nos
interesa
quizá reconozcan esto como un
semicírculo y cuál es el radio vamos de
menos 12 a menos 2 el diámetro es 10 por
lo que el radio es 5 lo dibujamos el
área de un círculo
por radio al cuadrado por lo que el área
del semicírculo espí por 25 entre 2 y
así de rápido sin tener que hacer
cálculos sofisticados encontramos el
valor de esto el área de un semicírculo
25 por pi entre 2 hagamos otro ejercicio
cual es la integral definida de menos 2
a 2 positivo de fx de x a que será igual
con base en lo que ya conocemos para
esta función de igual a fx vamos de
menos 2 a 2 por lo que nos interesa esta
área quizás su mente ya se dio cuenta de
que esto se encuentra por debajo del eje
x por lo que será un área negativa pero
primero calculemos el área usando un
poco de geometría y después ya que
identificamos que es un área por debajo
del eje la pondremos como área negativa
la geometría nos dice que el área de un
triángulo es base por altura entre 2
escribimos un medio por la base que va
de menos 2 a 2
y la altura parece que es 3 por lo que
multiplicamos un medio por 4 por 3 lo
que nos da igual a 6 podemos vernos
tentados a escribir aquí 6 ya que es el
área que acabamos de encontrar pero
recuerden que nos encontramos por debajo
del eje x así que esto será menos 6
hagamos un último ejercicio calculemos
la integral definida de menos 12 a 2
positivo de fx de x lo escribimos así
pero en futuros vídeos veremos en
detalle qué significa esta de x para la
anotación de integrales a que será igual
esto pausa en el vídeo y traten de
calcularlo será esta área y esta otra
área pero no podemos sumar 25 por pi
entre 2 + 6
tal cual recuerden que esta es una
integral negativa es menos 6 por lo que
será un área positiva 25 por pi entre 2
menos esta área que está debajo del eje
x menos 6
este ejemplo en particular este es el
valor de la integral definida y con esto
terminamos